je reçois maintenant jacques attali pour
la parution chez fayard de son
dictionnaire du 21e siècle sous forme de
mosaïque de mots un ouvrage dans lequel
l'ex conseiller du président mitterrand
et ex patron de la berd développe avec
science et sens de l'anticipation
sa vision du futur jacques attali
bonsoir soit donc avant on va en venir
très rapidement livre avant donc vous
êtes né à alger en 43 vous dites souvent
que c'est un pays fantôme qui existent
plus bien entendu enfin votre algérie
avoue n'existe plus vous avez vos
racines dans la tête
récemment vous recommander pour
l'algérie l'envoi de brigades
internationales un peu comme cela a été
fait en espagne pendant la guerre civile
vous pensez sérieusement à ça je pense
qu'il faudrait le proposait continuer de
proposer sans cesse naturellement ça
peut pas être fait sans l'accord du
gouvernement algérien clé si le
gouvernement algérien se révèle
incapable de régler ce problème alors il
faudra bien qu'ils acceptent l'aide de
la communauté internationale en tant que
juifs d'algérie comme vous êtes proclamé
auprès du président chadli vous vous
feriez partie de ces brigades
internationales
faut pas pousser le ridicule jusqu'à
imaginer que je puisse remplacer des
professionnels comme ceux qui auront à
le faire mais si à ma place de peu jouer
en rouge le ferait avec avec conscience
et plaisir très bien vous êtes arrivé en
france dans les informer trop pole parce
qu'à l'époque c'est la métropole dans
les années dans les années cinquante et
un peu plus tôt même que que vos parents
vous ont envoyé à paris pour faire des
études c'est ça vous fait polytechnique
de sorties majeures à l'âge de 20 ans
bravo sciences po les mines l'ena est ce
que c'est à cause de toutes ces grandes
écoles que claude allègre vous a demandé
de réfléchir à la réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur j'imagine que
c'est une des raisons j'étais aussi
enseignant à l'université et dans les
grandes écoles universités c'est une des
raisons qui a motivé sans doute que le
gouvernement me demande de présider une
commission réformer vous avez formé
vraiment que les commissions pour
réformer l'enseignement c'est pas pour
dire mais un camus quelques-unes
oui vous avez raison tout mon idée c'est
d'éviter que ce soit un rapport de plus
posé sur une étagère et pour ça il faut
à la fois que la réforme soit ambitieuse
et qu'on arrive à en convaincre donc tel
rapport n'a de sens que s'il convainc
ont déconné françois mitterrand dans les
années 70
c'est en 81 vous avez été nommé dans
conseiller spécial où c'est déjà dur et
191 donc dix ans auprès de lui dans le
petit bureau à côté ce qui a dû
d'ailleurs vous attirer plus grands
bureaux de vous attirer pas mal de
rancune parce que tous les gens
évidemment qui est obligé de passer chez
vous pour aller le voir dois de vous en
vouloir ensuite la berd jusqu'en 93 donc
la banque européenne de reconstruction
et de développement
voilà donc vous avez une idée faut bien
le dire et maintenant vous dirigiez du
pense toujours une société qui s'appelle
à ea qui fait du conseil en stratégie
ans les gouvernements
voilà qui vous conseillez des
gouvernements étrangers essentiellement
les gouvernants c'est bien c'est bien
payé vous avez publié quand même 26
essais et romans
c'est pas mal vous êtes un peu
graphomane faut bien le dire alors je
descends en commun avec gallo que nous
avons reçus la semaine dernière et
giesbert
nous avons suivi récent en commun d'être
des surhommes quoi dire que le izik vous
vous étiez de quatre heures à 8 heures
du matin pour que tous les jours 7 jours
sur 7 et le matin je ne sais pas écrire
le soir ouais vous dormez pas beaucoup
quand même non pas trop non mais combien
parmi 4 e
ah oui ça c'est bien parce que tous les
gens qui nous regardent et disent merde
il faut pas essayer faux pas sur ses
toits destructif
moi je ne le fais que parce que je le
fais naturellement vous est pas mauvaise
mine
je cours un petit plusieurs quatre
heures par les soucis lady blue avec
dedans mais vraiment on peut et vous
travaillez en plus voulait toujours
dirigé la septième de beethoven non je
suis en train d'y travailler
ah ouais c'est vrai alors j'ai c'est
très sérieux bon alors on va en arriver
au livre donc effectivement c'est comme
vous l'appelez dans un petit texte
liminaire une encyclopédie de l'avenir
un testament prénatal or c'est un
oxymoron 1 quand on dit ça oui c'est à
dire une contradiction entre deux maux
de nous qu'il a la cote et de l'autre
son contrat d'ici sont antinomiques
comme la force tranquille un peu
exactement le dictionnaire pourquoi
gbagbo c'est facile d'accès pourquoi
vous avez choisi la forme du
dictionnaire pour faire de la cites
avait peut-être d'abord pas par
impossibilité de faire autrement
j'ai réfléchi je voulais tout dire sur
ce que j'avais en tête sur le 21e siècle
et le traité sous forme d'une thèse ou
et et est réducteur on veut pas réduire
ce qui vient à une thèse il ya trop de
choses contradictoires et le
dictionnaire permet de raconter des
choses contradictoires et en même temps
je crois que c'est qu'il est ainsi que
la navigation du voyage
de l'association d'idées bizarre quand
dictionnaire permet merveilleusement de
faire il ya que c'est un mot un mot vous
avez beaucoup c'est le mot nomades
nomadisme et c'est vrai qu'à l'inter
d'un dictionnaire on peut être on peut
être nomade et puis c'est effectivement
une façon de décrire le monde par tas de
petites permet à tout un chacun à
l'entrée où il veut de choisir ça
m'amuse toujours de voir quels mots les
gens choisissent d'abord ouais moi je
veux dire après alors alors c'est une
ambition total s'est même légèrement aux
prétentieux quand même alors les
questions auxquelles vous aurez pour des
sera-t-il possible de nourrir tous les
hommes pourra-t-on éliminer la pauvreté
y aura-t-il du travail pour tout le
monde les sciences bouleverseront tels
les modes de vie au foie jeunes gens
pour savoir quelle guerre quelle
catastrophe écologique menaceront
comment seront gérés les contradictions
entre liberté solidarité
quand on dit ça on dit colossale quand
même un oui mais maintenant ce sont des
questions qu'il faut se poser parce
qu'on va entrer dans une période aussi
radicalement neuve sans se poser ces
questions et j'ai essayé de faire le
point sur tout ce que la science peut
dire en même temps de rêver et
d'imaginer de créer
quitte à me tromper et sûrement et
ensuite changer la vie mais je crois
qu'il est très important d'essayer très
pour moi ces questions mais vous dites
c'est pas parce qu'on peut pas prédire
l'avenir qu'on va essayer de l'inventer
c'est assez c'est assez joli
alors il ya un texte effectivement un
texte liminaire où vous vous parlez de
toutes les fausses prévisions qui ont
été faites on s'est assez bien ça de
bêtisiers et et ouais il ya des trucs
qu'ils ont une terrible par exemple
c'est le président de 2,10 bm qui disait
qu'on ne vendrait pas plus de quatre
ordinateurs sur dans le monde où le
président de digital équipement qui
disait que personne n'aurait jamais un
ordinateur à domicile le club de rome si
karen o des rois ou qui dirait qu'on
aurait pu d'énergie l'occasion voilà
deux prix nobel américain qui ont
expliqué que l'union soviétique serait
la première puissance de la planète
avant la saint-valentin deux là c'est
vrai que ça rend ça doit rendre humble
tous les futurologues et vous dites
d'ailleurs à ce sujet là que les vrais
futurologue enfin ceux qui imaginent le
mieux sont les auteurs finale des
romanciers les romanciers surtout les
romanciers science fiction moi je suis
un fou de science fiction
je veux parler d' arthur cycle art oui
je n'ai but we azim of robert thalheim
jules verne a été un de ceux qui a le
mieux vu
début du chèque ce qu'allait être le 21e
siècle 20e siècle a fallu adapter
sauf que les auteurs d'inscriptions se
trouve aussi sur deux choses
essentielles qui sont l'esthétique et
les moeurs sur lequel en général ils
sont hors taxes and wagons qui tiennent
pas compte de ça oui vous avez pas me
philip k.dick dans votre liste j'aurais
pu mais d'acteurs du bic rassurez moi
non sans mal même en sus béquilles et
ouais je sais ce qui se passe en second
avec le virtuel c'est la gtz et déjà
c'était déjà alors moi je suis allé voir
un peu les mots évidemment c'est ça donc
d'abord je suis allé vers les mots que
je connaissais pas parce que vous créez
des mots vous créez ados l'écran en ckoi
ados l'écran ado l'écran c'est pas une
création de moi tout à fait puisque
c'est d'ailleurs voilà ça y est ça a
commencé à surgir aux états unis avec
screenagers c'est l'idée qu'on est à la
fois dans l'écran est rien en dehors
c'est bien qu'on mélange la vie réelle
et la vie a virtuellement pas seulement
l'écran télé mais aussi les grandes
lorgnette et demain la troisième
dimension du virtuel alors ça vous
surprendra pas je suis allé voir sur les
voir sex là j'ai pas trouvé sexe mais
j'ai trouvé sexualité alors le 21e
siècle sexualité jacques attali il sera
d'abord évidemment comme comme comme
toujours depuis tant de temps que ça a
semé mais aussi comme dans beaucoup
d'autres domaines avec la virtualité qui
va s'introduire et pour beaucoup de gens
la possibilité ou là l'impuissance à
tous les sens du mot qui consiste à en
avoir une sexualité que virtuelle avec
toutes les perspectives qui s'ouvrent
d'abord sur les simples jeux vidéo du
virtuel mais demain la virtualité à
trois dimensions
d'où les personnages que j'imaginais que
j'appelle clown image image absolument
qu'on pourra avoir son temps pour la
sexualité que pour le travail oit soir
c'est soit par exemple avoir spammé
marilyn monroe qui nuit devant soi qui
exhale amour avec sais pas avec qui au
bout d'arsenal se bousculer dans pas
très longtemps dans moins d'un siècle
on saura faire des clones images qu'on
pourra toucher ce qui est le touchant
évidemment là on transmet le son et
l'image mais on pourra transmettre le
toucher la saveur et le goût et l'odeur
et l'odorat donc il est à ce moment là
tous les éléments de la sexualité en
tout cas dans sa matérialité des ronces
euro réunis c'est dommage qu'on est là
on n'y sera pas
j'ai pas sur ce soit dommage avant alors
chez les voir drogue series étonnera pas
beaucoup alors là vous dit que
effectivement c'est un peu ce qu'on voit
maintenant déjà c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui en france on interdit le
6 la marijuana m'enfin tout le monde
prend du
valium prendre du transaction je
commence à peine nous en apprend pas
mais il ya plein de trucs lexomil enfin
bon les gens du prozac tout ça on va
aller vers ce à quoi je pense qu'on ira
on ira aussi vers la vers la
légalisation tout parce que parce que la
prohibition a montré avec l'alcool que
ça ne fait que développer l'économie
criminelle et que et et la drogue en vo
vous avez vous quelles nouvelles disent
qu'ils en deviennent mots très important
la drogue c'est un voyage dans beaucoup
de langues d'ailleurs c'est le même mot
donc c'est un des formes de voyage que
l'humanité va permettre et je crois
qu'on va aller vers sa légalisation mais
en même temps sa maîtrise oui alors bon
en fait ce qu'on voit en malheureusement
on peut pas tous passer en revue mais on
voit que ce sera à peu près les mêmes
problèmes y aura des guerres il y aura y
aura là il y aura aussi bien des guerres
que des famines la tyrannie murale la
démocratie va d'après votre livre
s'accroître enfin en termes de
territoire est-ce qu'on va pas vers une
société à un peu benetton c'est-à-dire
métis et uniformiser s'envole de galit à
rythmes
j'espère que non je crois que la
civilisation qui vient je l'appelle
civile légaux avec un double jeu de mots
d'abord le jeu de lego statut chacun
peut choisir des éléments et je crois
qu'on va les non pas vers une
civilisation uniforme je crois
absolument pas la domination de
l'anglais mais croit que on va vers une
civilisation où chacun pourra prendre
des éléments mais choisir sa propre
vision un peu comme on le voit dans la
musique où chaque musicien prend des
morceaux asiatiques africains est un
terreau du sampling quoi voilà
mais le lego c'est aussi l apostrophe
ego c'était une humiliation personnelle
égoïsme individualisé alors en termes de
carrière vous avez donc une ascension
absolument exceptionnel c'est un des
hommes les plus puissants de france
pendant pendant une dizaine d'années
après j'ai quand même eu deux gros de
gros problèmes et verbatim en pas
raconter toute l'histoire ici enfin
disons votre ami elie wiesel a pas été
tendre avec vous le président mitterrand
a émis des réserves parce que vous
disiez qu'il n'avait pas cru à la
réunification allemande
vous en avez assisté signe vous perdre
partout oui c'est ça ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir aujourd'hui si j'étais
si je ne change rien bon d'accord il
n'ya pas cru non non je persiste temps
sur chaques sur le support est ce que
j'aurai les visuels bien entendu et puis
l'histoire de la berre lors il sort de
la berd c'est que vous quand vous étiez
au conseil d'état ou m'aviez dit saad en
bain de minuit il ya une dizaine
d'années vous gagnez 20 mille francs par
mois ce qui n'était pas énorme compte
tenu des études poussées que vous avez
fait et quand vous avez installé la berd
à londres vous avez dépensé pour
l'installer 55 millions de livres ce qui
fait quand même 550 millions de francs à
peu près ce qu'il fait pour les gens 55
milliards de centimes maman donc on a
parlé mais d'abord c'est ce qu'a été
pris d'un coup comme ça un peu comme les
80 la folie des grandeurs là c'est juste
que le rien dans cette affaire c'est que
j'ai eu peur de ne pas me défendre
davantage un cette décision de créer ce
bâtiment n'a pas été prises par moi mais
par un comité dont je ne faisais pas
partie de cet argent était de l'argent
britannique contrôlé par les
britanniques n'ont pas un sou de
dépenses excessives au delà du budget a
été fait 3 j'ai pris aucune décision
qu'on a ensuite reprochées commettre
dumars dans les couloirs étaient de 4 la
moindre institutions internationales
regardez bruxelles regarder loin
regarder le fonds monétaire est
infiniment plus luxueuse que cette
institution là c'était un mauvais procès
donc vous vous en faites vous avez vous
avez regretté susanna dit je vous avais
dit j'aurais dû prendre deux semaines de
vacances parce que j'ai craqué j'étais
énervé j'étais fatigué je suis parti
avant même qu'on me met dehors en gros
personne ne m'a demandé par voie là et
en fait après vous avez regretté
oui oui vous étiez utile enfants c'est à
dire j'ai eu l'idée de cette institution
j'ai eu le privilège incroyable pour moi
en tout cas d'être le solde fit la
guerre d'avoir l'idée d'une institution
internationale de la cré de trouver 10
milliards de dollars en trois mois 1 4 -
pour un mâle comme food riser là pour
faire la première institution qu'elle
est de l'est et j'ai claqué la porte et
j'ai laissé mon bébé un peu même avant
qu'ils sachent marché qui va bien pas
très bien alors bon il a encore persiste
et signe rien n'a changé bilan un peu
quoi si vous êtes né en corée mans 43
ans maintenant je voulais être le hareng
le raymond aron de la gauche
vous l'avez pas été c'est pas vous
croyez je ne sais pas non je vous
faisais que patricia ne seront pas de
jugement non jeu d'abord comment vous ne
vous n'oubliez pas cette ambition
non c'est j'essaye d'avoir mis
l'ambition parce que je crois que je le
dis dans le livre qu'on n'a pas une vie
unique c'est d'avoir une des multiples
je refuse de me mettre dans une seule
catégorie mais raymond aron était dans
une
le catégorie et si je peux toujours
légale et dans sa lucidité dans
l'analyse j'essaye mais je veux pas
n'être qu'une seule chose de l'or
jacques delors avait dites vous que vous
aviez l'étape d'un futur nobel de
l'économie
on verra bien d'accord donc vous donner
encore avant avant qu'on se quitte je
suis demandé juste une chose je vais
raconter une histoire un jour qui m'a
beaucoup fait rire c'est les 5 juifs
qu'on change le monde voulait pas me la
raconter chaque juif qui ont changé le
monde le premier c'est moïse qui a dit
que tout était dans la loi le second
c'est jésus qui a dit que tout est dans
l'amour le troisième c'est freud qui a
dit que tout échec ce le quatrième c'est
marx qui a dit que tout est argent est
le cinquième c'est engine qui a dit que
tout était fait merci merci je vais
montrer votre livre donc voilà j'ai
montré à cette caméra
le dictionnaire du 21e siècle donc
jacques attali chez fayard merci
beaucoup très heureux de vous avoir reçu
ravi d'être venu vous voir il pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible